do you want to do just quick intro
obviously you've all been on the podcast
but for those of you that you know may
not know who you are Amber I'll come to
you first do a quick intro and then
we've got Alex Carl and then we'll kick
off
um hi everyone so I'm Amber I've been in
recruitment for five years now
um and in that time have spent the
entirety of that at the same agency but
plot twist actually quit that company
last week
so I'm unemployed the first unemployed
guest costumes ever had on the Pod
um and I'm going to be starting on my
own Venture so lots of exciting things
to come Alex thanks
[Applause]
hello everyone I'm Alex I am I have been
in recruitment since 2003 so I'm the old
person on the panel
um I built a business which I sold in
2016. I'm now a shareholder in another
recruitment company strive
yeah
no one else clapped that's really
never mind
um I also have started investing in the
Recruitment and HR Tech space so I've
got a couple of investments in that
space
um and yeah that's me nice Kyle
hello I'm Kyle sales director uh this is
prime are we going to get away here we
go
there was a few more there you won
um so I'm Kyle sales director at this is
prime uh we support predominantly tech
companies in growing their sales teams
on a mission to change the perception of
sales and make it a career of choice for
all young people entering the industry
so that's me nice cool so let's get into
it uh I think I'm going to start Amber
by quoting you with something you shared
with me sorry to put you straight on the
spot but look most people that I've
spoken to over the last couple of months
would describe first quarter of this
year is quite challenging different and
hard but in preparation for this these
are Amber's thoughts and let's just sort
of talk about it so Amber shared with me
I don't personally think recruitment is
harder in 2023 complacency has increased
as has the amount of internal ta teams
utilizing job boards due to the
recession
thoughts is about that thought process
let's start there
I'm such a hypocrite
it is bloody hard at the minute like
that's just the reality but having said
that complacency has also increased like
if I look at the majority of recruiters
we are kind of scrapping for companies
that aren't necessarily they have a good
brand reputation they have like for
example I work in the US they have 401ks
that are actually competitive or I just
feel like a lot of us
due to the recession are letting our
guards down in terms of what we will
accept from clients and we're focusing
on maintenance versus growth a lot of
the times with recruitment companies
right now
um so yeah Alex anything to add to
Amber's thoughts on you know complacency
over it being more challenging
yeah the market is definitely tough at
this moment in time and
I think for
I think it's particularly tough for
people who are coming into the market at
this moment because they probably
haven't seen the good times certainly
someone who started in the last quarter
or two is probably coming in and
thinking what on Earth have I set myself
up for look maintenance is important as
is growth I think it's also just
important to be able to embrace the suck
a little bit and understand that you're
going through a period where
um yeah things might be a bit at
this moment in time you're probably not
going to be earning the commission that
you wanted to be earning
um previously but certainly you know
good times will always be Round the
Corner again within recruitment so nice
well look let's sort of build on that
then so Carl let me come to you and
start this sort of initial part of this
around you know business development
that that typically when we talk about
things being difficult obviously can the
candidate side can always be a challenge
but typically what I'm hearing is you
know clients are being hesitant
um a number of accounts that people hope
were making as many highs as their hopes
on just the BD side tends to be
difficult so I guess let's just start
high level uh if we were to reflect on
you know q1 what have been from your
side some of the you know most effective
ways for you guys to maintain client
acquisition you know maintain some of
the the job flow that you hope for
what's been working for you guys in q1
on on the BD client acquisition side
let's just start there
yeah I think what's been working for us
and it's important to say
um we kind of restructured our model
towards the back end of last year
um and we now have a dedicated business
development team which consists of sdrs
which I think is somewhat unusual maybe
for recruitment businesses so we've got
a team of three people now that's core
responsibility is all day looking to
generate opportunities for recruiters or
other people in the business to then
subsequently close and bring on roles so
that so far has been really working for
us to have that dedicated focus and
people that can become experts in
creating opportunities I think um what's
been really useful for us as well is the
cold calling just going back to basics
um did some analysis of the clients that
we've brought on within the last six
months and 30 of them have originated
from a cold call so
30 yeah so I think for us having the
focus of people in the business that
that's all that they do
and also just you know hitting the
phones as well has been quite effective
for us cool so let's just talk about
this for a sec because you know picking
up the phone has become really not
sexy basically has it you know
no one likes to do that so Amber I'm
going to bring it back to you you know I
was gonna do this didn't you so uh for
those of you that haven't listened to
the podcast that me and uh amber did I
think we even called it like you know
cold calling is dead or something
clickbait like that but anyway
preparation for this Amber literally
said to me
um I've gone from you know not believing
in cold calling to becoming a cold
calling Queen so let's you know let's
talk about if that's been effective for
you Carl that's been effective for you
you know a third of the job
opportunities have come from that method
so let's talk about this so I guess
question for you Amber is you know
you've had a bit of a shift of mindset
talk to us about one what does what did
that actually look like how did you go
about that because people could benefit
from that here yeah again I'm a
hypocrite a running theme
um but with multi-channel BD I think
naturally as as salespeople and as
recruiters we focus on the parts of that
that we're really good at and that's the
negative that I think I had I love I
love cold emailing like I love really
personalizing them and making them
amazing and I was getting really really
good responses from that but I also
recognize that I need to look at other
avenues as well and yeah like you said
funnily enough I came on your podcasts
and was slating cold calling saying that
it's dead blah blah blah but when in
reality I was just
I was terrible I'd spent all of this
time educating myself and reading about
and learning about cold emailing and you
know personal branding on LinkedIn but
quite honestly it terrified me like I
hated especially for me working in
executive Search in biotech these are
CEOs in America of like huge molecular
biology companies they don't want to
talk to me and I'm a sensitive person
and it really knocked my confidence
quite honestly like just being told to
politely a foot off down the phone and
for example I was telling you both like
earlier that I made 260 dials yesterday
and I got one person that picked up the
phone wow and it's just like
self-deprecating that doesn't sound
productive no it's not but then last
week yeah I did I think it was 33 and I
got two amazing BDS and now I've got
like two VP roles from one of them so
yeah I think what I've learned is just
like focus on the things that scare you
and and really try and better yourself
because there are not a lot of
recruiters at the moment that are
picking up the phone I think a lot of
graduates especially are forgetting that
this is a sales job like yes
there are other avenues that we can use
but you need to be doing all of them
because they all marry so well because
when I am doing the cold calls I'm then
following up with a personalized like
amazing email that's less than 70 words
that's got a really good call to action
um so yeah I think as well when you look
at the best recruiters are the people
that recognize that you need to be
constantly learning and evolving like
I'm constantly calling myself a
hypocrite because one minute I think
that I'm really good at something in the
next minute I realized that actually you
need a bit of work on that
um so yeah nice Alex how do you feel
about this mate you know you've been in
a game for a while you're probably
thinking these Lots I told them
you know trying to drive this since
2003. come full circle what you know
what you're seeing in strive you know do
you see similar numbers in terms of
opportunities generated from cold
calling how do you feel about it firstly
that's really ageist sorry so
so you dude sorry mate sorry
um secondly
um yeah I think for me it's all about
data so I'm like a massive data geek and
I think what you have to do is is have a
standardized way of doing something
which is effectively your mapped out
process based around
um best practice for each aspect of your
um your prospecting if you do that I
think that hit the nail on the head what
Amber was saying there you can
understand what's working and what isn't
working if you don't have a standardized
way of of doing something the problem is
when you get results it can happen for
all sorts of reasons if you have a
standardized approach it's really easy
to be able to identify exactly what's
working as you go through your sales
funnel depending upon what channel and
how many touches you're making based
upon different channels and approaches I
think
that gives you the ability to understand
the different levers you have to pull
depending upon market conditions so
talking about 230 odd calls leading to
you know your reach rate I'm assuming
was really poor maybe previously you had
a 10 15 Retreat all of a sudden you
reach rates gone down to one two percent
so clearly therefore you can see that
you're either going to have to increase
the volume of your cold calling or you
need to look at that and say well are
there other things that we can do from a
root cause perspective such as you know
your data quality maybe if we had better
data quality we'd be able to call more
mobile numbers therefore we need to look
at our providers etc etc so I think it's
just about having a standardized
approach where you can really analyze
what you're doing on a granular granular
level both from a volume perspective but
also from a conversion flow perspective
because if you're doing those calls and
that's leading to an X rate reach rate
then you get you know what percentage of
those calls that you do get through to
what percentage of those are positive
versus negative once you get through to
your positive calls what percentage of
those are leading to discos once you get
to your discos what percentage of those
are leading to
um you know signed contracts etc etc so
by understanding that data you can
really start to hone in on what is and
what isn't working so previously CV
specs would have been amazing because in
a buoyant Market where everyone's
fighting over candidates you might be
sending out CVS and getting a 15 reply
rate all of a sudden that's dropped down
to five percent it gives you that
ability to understand what's working and
what isn't working and then that kind of
gives you the ability to be able to pull
those levers to figure out what you
should be doing moving forward so
obviously it sounds a lot I know we're
going quite granular here but obviously
we're talking about cadences really
aren't we I feel like yes sir who can
you because I want to make sure everyone
you know can you put your hand up if
you've heard this terminology cadences
before
you know what's that would you say
quarter of the room
so that so just to make this really
clear here because I think what what's
going on here obviously Carl you
recruiting you know the Texas space so
the strive Amber I know you take a lot
of learnings from different Industries
and then bring this into recruitment so
just in Alex you were just explaining
there just for like really Layman symbol
terms you know this word Cadence not
everyone's heard it standardized process
like what does that actually look like
what does actually mean I've got an
example that Amber's given me but how
would you describe this everyone here
will put their hand up and knows what
that actually means so your your Cadence
is your sales process for prospecting so
if it's a multi-channel multi-touch
Cadence what you've typically got is if
you think about all your different
routes to Market all your different
channels you've got phone you've got
sales emails you've got CV specs
LinkedIn social touches voicemails voice
notes uh LinkedIn emails all those
different Avenues to prospect what you
do is you put that into a logical manner
where you have a standardized approach
where day one you do X they do two you
do y and you can have multiple touches
on each day you prioritize those based
upon their effectiveness so let's say
you've typically got a two or three week
Cadence where you Prospect 30 accounts
and you follow the same pattern
to prospect those accounts which should
produce the best return on effort based
upon the work that you do so if you're
doing that consistently you can
understand your sales funnel and you can
say that based upon X Y and Z every two
weeks that I run this Cadence with a
particular account this is the likely
return I'm going to get on that and
again going back to that previous point
the real Joyce sourcewell is an example
great great product because what that
does is it gives you the ability to
analyze your Cadence and understand
exactly what's working and what isn't
working so that you can constantly
measure and optimize it cool
bit more that is that does that help
yeah cool so and then just to you know
just just tie this up and then we'll
move on Amber gave me an example so Alex
has gave a really good um example there
but Amber gave me a bit of an example
because we prepared for this so for
example
um the uh Cadence the Amber showed me
was day one personalized email and Coco
uh day two inmail and cold call day
three another email with a different
personalized potential problem day five
LinkedIn post about business Etc
etcetera to get what I mean so what's
really helpful because look all I do is
speak to recruiters you know you have
people go into the office like you know
I'm gonna do what's your day plan today
Alex well 10 to 12 when I do BD right
what the does that mean do you know
what I mean and this is where this this
really helps you know what is the
process we're going to take our Dream
clients that we hope you know we could
do some great work with
um through that journey and then because
you have that Journey you can recognize
clean it for you oh actually people were
yeah affected the cold calling and yeah
for me sorry to buy it like last year I
UK right but then I got to the end of
the year and I thought I don't have a
single repeat client like this has all
just been reactive BD and I can't keep
this up so a Cadence for me is enabled
me to not just Chase vacancies but Chase
businesses
and that's been the biggest like mindset
switch for me and it's just become so
much easier since doing that so yeah
agreement yes okay cool right just to
just keep it uh on the on the BD side
for a second curious Carl come to you
um how do we feel about if you were to
look at again q1 how you
um the types of companies and and work
you've been doing what how have you been
fine you know just doing contingent
exclusive retained how has that played
out for you guys in queue on you know
everyone's saying I never I'm never
going to work continue only work
retained most people I speak to on the
contingent hamster wheel you know what
what what's that look like in terms of
the products and services that you find
in contingent is mainly how you work is
it exclusive talk to us a bit about how
that's played out
I would love to sit here and tell you
and say it's all retained exclusive it's
not a lot of it is contingent um a big
thing that's been effective was though
it's more so been exclusivity because
that's at least given us some security
of not missing out to competitors or
other agencies and we have had some
access uh successfully we've retained um
so a bit of upfront commitment which are
still getting that but it's just harder
to secure now because so many businesses
are a risk-averse so yeah mixture of
contingent um but exclusive has been a
huge push for us as well
Alex and you know if you're looking at
the data and stuff what how does it
Shape Up in and strive in terms of you
know the different products and services
well we're definitely doing less retain
than we were based upon market
conditions I think you've got to combine
I think sometimes people get a bit too
fixated on
um contingent exclusive retained without
looking at what the most important thing
alongside that is which is fill rate so
I think you've got to understand your
fill weights and I think you've also got
to then look at that from a volume
perspective amazing if you can retain
business but the reality is if you can't
win it in an offer volume to be able to
then feed yourself or feed the business
if you've got a BD function I think
you've got to be a little bit
strategic with regards to that I I don't
think contingent's always sorry I don't
think retained is always the right the
right way to go
um and I think you can set yourself up
to fail quite a lot with retained
because if you're not 100 confident
you're going to be able to fill that job
within a certain time scale you probably
shouldn't be taking you shouldn't be
taking on obtain business because you're
going to dedicate loads of time and
resource to a role that you're not going
to feel you're going to piss the client
off you've given certain reassurances
and guarantees from a retained
perspective so I just think you've got
to be a little bit smart with that and
you can't you know retained is great but
it's not the be-all and end-all I think
um exclusive business can be fantastic
because you don't necessarily have to
um die on your sword if you don't film
that job and then just from just quickly
your perspective fill rates what what
you're saying stand up what would you
expect is like the gold standard that
you'd always be aiming for at strive 100
on every single job come on okay what is
it 13
um
I hope not
we're now um our retained rate is
exceptionally High okay um and that's
for a reason because we take on business
which we know we're going to fill yeah
because again the problem is most of the
time with a retained role you're
guaranteeing fill typically so again you
can waste a lot of time and energy on
roles if you're not going to feel them
on retained because you've kind of made
that that packed with the client
um exclusive our fuel rates are also
extremely high but obviously not as good
as retained and then contingent you know
I I'm not a massive fan of contingent
but I think it depends upon the market
and I think it depends upon the business
model there are companies out there that
absolutely smash it they're in
contingent so you know there's lots of
different ways to to skin a cat and I
think it is a little bit dependent upon
the market you work in and also your
business model okay fair so
um just to bring in an audience
questionnaire I think would be a good
time to ask it we've spoken a lot about
having a process cadences this is a
question uh from Felix who basically
said when your pipeline dries up how
long do you continue to trust your same
process before you try something new I
don't know if you have any thoughts on
that yeah that that 100 is all data-led
because if your process worked
previously the key is that you should
understand why your process worked and
that you know if you look at the two
important bits around your sales funnel
there's the volume of things that you do
and then there's the conversion rate
between each stage of the funnel so if
you understand what that is you should
have a good understanding of why your
Cadence works and why it doesn't work
when it starts going wrong you should
therefore be able to identify why it's
going wrong and that gives you the
ability I think to Pivot and make
changes which might be increasing volume
you know but I think that's a bit of a
lazy answer that a lot of managers use
just do more
um I think it's it's helpful to
understand that if you're if your
conversion rate from disco to new logo
or you're saying disco let everyone
understands Discovery so doing a
discovery call with a client okay cool
no I just you know I want to make sure
everyone sure yeah okay so again I just
think it's data-led if you understand
how like I see it sometimes and this is
a little bit like sport some people who
are just really good at something they
don't actually know how they do it and
you have these gifted recruiters and
they just do stuff and it works and
that's amazing but at the same time I
think as a as a business you really have
to dig into that and figure out what
that looks like and the reasons why
something works and then yeah I've kind
of forgotten the question but that gives
you the ability it's like yeah when
should you you know change your process
whatever well then the data will tell
you let the data be your guide okay cool
yeah sorry
for example I'd suggest a new technique
and then they come back to me and say oh
this doesn't work like I've been trying
it for two weeks that doesn't
necessarily mean that you need to change
the entirety of that technique it could
just be a small aspect of that so for
example if I'm talking about cold
calling it could be your opener it could
be your CTA you don't need to completely
flip the script it's a b testing right
so pick a small part change that trial
it for two weeks if it fails change it
but you need it to be long enough to
understand the flaws but short enough to
not be wasting your time okay nice so I
think I want to bring this in so Alex I
was looking at some of your posts you've
really upped the the posting game mate
which I know good content and one of
your posts right we have a lot of
rhetorics in the room and you know from
what I see it's a selling point that the
company they're representing doesn't
work to kpis right
and you're talking about data right so
your postage on a referencing let's just
talk about for a second recruiters if
you're not using kpis to track and
improve your performance you're either
really really good or you just don't
care anymore
so you know like maybe we've gone too
far the like you know for me I've been
saying to people okay well let's change
the wording it's about what is the
science to be successful you know I
think it's really useful for people to
know what should the inputs look like
um rather than no we don't do kpis you
know we treat you like an adult do we do
we'll support you so let's just talk
about that for a sec because you're
saying this is absolutely integral
um you know have we gone too far towards
yeah kpis we treat people like
adults not not believing in kpis is like
not believing in cause and effect
because I think the key for me is that
there's three types of metric you've got
activities you've got objectives and
you've got results if you want to
achieve a certain result you need to
reverse engineer that back into the
objectives you need to achieve which
lead to that result to get to those
objectives you need to do certain
activities and that's not just volume
right because I think people get fixated
on the volume piece with kpis as if it's
just more and more and more it's also
about the quality of what you do and if
the quality isn't right you won't have
the necessary conversion rate going
through your funnel so if you break your
metrics down into activities objectives
results you can reverse engineer that
stuff and say by the end of this quarter
I want to achieve X from a results
perspective that means I need to achieve
certain objectives over the course of
the quarter and in turn I need to feed
into those objectives with certain
activities so it gives you the ability
it's kind of like a golden thread right
between your metrics I can look into the
future and say this week if I do a
certain number of activities and I do it
to the right quality standards that will
lead me to a certain number of
objectives which in turn is my indicator
of like whether I'm going to achieve my
quarterly goal or not so
I just think it's it's about
understanding the science of your desk
get that stuff right you can look into
the future and then every week you say
look I haven't achieved the objectives
that I wanted to this week so I'm going
to have to change the inputs the
following week if I'm going to catch up
with regards to the objectives that I
need to achieve which again lead into
the results and then you combine that
with time blocking you can figure out
how to manage your diary you allocate
tasks and objectives within that time
span and it's just a constant way of
being able to evaluate what you're doing
and where that's going to go because
again I think the key is
that for me was always super
motivational because I just knew this is
what I've got to do this is where that's
going to go and this is what that's
going to lead to so it just gave me such
confidence that I was doing the right
things
um without that I'm just doing stuff and
I don't know what the outcome is going
to be and that for me Isn't
motivationally good so
um I think when we talk about kpis being
no good I think genuinely it's because
people don't go into enough detail or or
be thoughtful enough about how kpis lead
to predictable outcomes Okay cool so
let's move this on to more you know you
said about Amber you managing a team
obviously we're talking about you know
the data that should lead to success so
Kyle I'm going to come to you on this
one so this was
um a question from Jacob which I won
your thoughts on and then e-review can
jump in here so question is if a member
of your team is putting in the effort
but the results aren't there how long
would you persevere with them for
um it's a tricky one mate isn't it
because the one thing that you ask of
the people that you hire is that they do
apply themselves work hard and put the
effort in and I think first of all I
would go back to the beginning if
someone isn't performing what they're
putting in the effort I'd probably look
into it'll be first of all and think hey
have we hired the right person you know
we need to probably look at that process
first of all and then two what's our
onboarding and training like because if
they're doing everything that we're
asking but the results aren't coming
what do we need to be doing differently
first but to actually give an answer to
the question
um I would probably say three months and
that's probably a bit soft some people
may be a bit more firm on that in terms
of the results okay Alex
well I I would say three months
um because you ask of people to put the
effort in and I feel like it's it's our
job if they're doing that to make sure
they achieve it so that would be my take
Alex
yeah you've got to identify the Gap so
this is where you are currently this is
where I need you to be and this is the
time scale that we need to see some
improvements and I'm saying that in like
a really matter of fact way way right so
it doesn't come across very
compassionately but I think the
Challenge from my experience is a random
example you hire three people two of
them are performing to like really good
standards and one of them is
underperforming because it's just
they're just not picking it up quick
enough and they're not demonstrating the
ability to assimilate information and
then action it to get the required
results the challenge you've got there
is you end up spending like 75 of your
time with the person who's
underperforming and then what's the well
12 and a half percent with the two
people who actually are performing to a
high standard and probably have a higher
potential to be quite Frank from an
early perspective so I think that that
could be Death By A Thousand Cuts and
then before you know it it's 9 12 months
down the line that person's still
underperforming compared to the standard
of high performance you have in your
business and they probably end up
leaving anyway because no one enjoys not
being successful right so I think your
time gets sucked into individuals and
this sounds really harsh but it's kind
of a question of maths where should I
spend my coaching time should it be with
the people who've got really high
potential or should it be with those
should I be spending a disproportionate
amount of time with actually the people
who've got the lowest potential and my
answer to that would be no so I think
you've got to allocate your time evenly
between your people and then the ones
that aren't keeping up you've just got
to be really compassionate but also
pragmatic about it and identify where
those gaps are and say look here's the
time to go we're working to I'm going to
do X Y and Z to support you but this is
what I need back from you and these are
the results we need to see based upon
improving and getting better and you
know what if if that's not the case
maybe you know you should probably be
thinking about where you can go where
you can be successful
because no one wants to be coming into
work every day and feeling like
it's not working for them
yeah and for me I think you know sales
is such a numerical and quantifiable
driven realm and sometimes like for
example with me in my second year of
recruitment I was terrible and I almost
got sacked and I would have just loved
for in that moment rather than people
just having a magnifying glass on my
kpis and the data was that was helpful
for someone to just sit me down and be
like how are you like how is this making
you feel because it can be so draining
you know we talk about having these
processes and just going through those
and rinsing and repeating it can just
get draining and especially now as we're
approaching a recession it's really hard
on your mind so I think not only looking
at kpi gaps but like mental health gaps
as well is is really important for me at
least
so so let's just continue this
leadership conversation a lot of people
in the room who are either current
leaders or aspiring leaders I think look
we had a ton of questions through around
you know the typical managing you know
that leadership Journey along with your
own performance and I think um but you
you shared some really interesting
things in terms of few it's always been
about having really clear expectations
so did you want to just talk to us a bit
about you know your journey with
leadership you gave me some really good
examples of how you set the team up
um again we're going a bit granular here
but I think it'll be helpful did you
want to just talk a bit about you know
why that Clarity and clear expectation
is important and what they actually look
like with with your team yeah
um so I I made a lot of mistakes along
the way and you know as a industry we
talk about how difficult being a billing
manager is let alone a billing director
and that's what I was and it was Bloody
hard like I did not have the time that I
necessarily wanted to you know put into
the team and so when I did you know set
meetings for example just little things
like actually following along with that
because I'm sure we've all had managers
in the past whereby they're like okay
we're gonna meet on a Monday we're going
to go through your pipeline on a
Wednesday we're going to have a peek and
pit meeting on a Friday and none of it
happens so just when you're saying
things stick to it because that's going
to create the trust and the honesty and
that's then going to be reciprocated
with how they feel about you so I think
that's something that I really tried
um to adhere to and again just like
trying to instill
the traits into my team that I wanted so
for example we didn't exercise one day I
think I told you about this and we
thought about the three highest
performing Recruiters in our business
and what traits they all had within them
and what made them successful and then
we kind of thought about okay what kind
of non-negotiables can we Implement as a
team to hold each other accountable and
to try and instill the traits that these
people have that we all openly look up
to
um so yeah open communication actually
sticking to your word and really
reiterating your vision and your vision
because as a leader I think it's so
clear in our heads what our values and
Mission is but if you're not reiterating
that constantly to your team how the
heck are they ever going to want to
follow you and create this journey with
you yeah Carl gonna come to you because
you sort of share the similar experience
didn't you but just really quickly uh
what amber showed me in terms of you
know what a weekly monthly quarterly to
use that word Cadence again but from a
leadership standpoint to Ambush enemy
that every Monday team Monday kick off
30 45 minutes the other thing would be
pipeline reviews weekly potential
bottlenecks can um you know Amber
provide any coaching for these people uh
one to one's monthly
um and they're very much enjoyed in uh
involved in the agenda you do quarterly
reviews and then you do BD one-to-one
reviews immediately following a call
with you know as a rough cool weather so
just to give you a bit of a flavor I
guess on what some of those things could
look like but yeah I I asked all these
guys around you know what what can we do
to build high performance teams we all
want our teams to be succeeding we want
to be doing well it's obviously Amber
you just said they're around a really
cool exercise that you did in terms of
right let's all agree together let I
don't want to just tell you what you
should be let's obviously all arrive at
the same
um point so Carl why don't you share you
know the exercise that you did of your
team because you actually shared a
similar experience where you know sport
thought about your core values as a team
as a business and why did that end up
being impactful
yeah so we did some internal training
which was all around High performing
teams
um and then we were tasked individually
as our teams to go away and discuss
debate and come up with what were the
kind of three values behaviors
non-negotiables that we all needed to
live by and really buy into oh wow
um and I think why that really helped oh
all good yeah
just there hello testing
um so what we did was
um we all got together and discussed
like the things that we believed and I
think the point here is all about
accountability and trust and similar to
what Amber said rather than us dictating
these are the things actually getting
them involved getting them on the
journey means actually they hold each
other accountable to them now hold me
accountable to them you know everyone
and I think everyone's really bought in
and to give you an idea of the things
that we came up with
um number one was be relentless and
never give in which I think we stole
from Sir Alex Ferguson for the United
fans in the room but that was one uh two
was win and lose together which I think
in the current market conditions is kind
of really resonates with everyone at the
moment kind of in this together and then
the third one was um we don't take
ourselves too seriously but we take what
we do very seriously and we have them on
the board and you know we hold each
other to account to them so I think the
key is getting the team involved on the
journey and coming up with these things
is really important and just quickly
like how did you then arrive at those
you know did you have like a proper
brainstorming session did you book out
half a day you know Post-it notes out
all that like
90 minutes outside the office we said
this is the activity you need to all be
involved and they were encouraged to
share their ideas and then we we didn't
leave until we agreed on what the three
were yeah cool right so let's move this
on just to just a mixture of a few
different things and then for those of
you that you know might have some
questions specific questions for these
guys definitely start thinking about
those and I'll come out with a
microphone but so
a couple of things here firstly Amber
let me come to you so just quickly for
context
um how let's say last year Billings wise
how much of that was all U.S have you
only always done us because I can't
remember if it was all or you did some
in Europe how much
have you typically done in the US over
the last 12 months yeah it was all oh
okay cool
um talk to us about look I've spoken to
a lot of people
um you know who are really excited about
the US opportunity
um interview someone yesterday who did a
million quid in a year and in the UK he
did the biggest amount he did was 260.
so he was one of those classic stories
that we hear about how many of them
actually true don't know but you know
talk to us about your experience and
everyone you know what has really ended
up working in uh being successful in the
US market for people here that might
have aspirations to do more work in the
US yeah and I think I'm somewhat an
anomaly as well because I was just kind
of thrown into the deep end and I didn't
even think about
the challenges that working in the US
market would present because I joined a
cold desk I didn't even know the meaning
of the industry that I work within which
is multi-omics like I barely do now to
be honest
um so whilst I've done that the whole
time I'm not necessarily sure if I'm the
best person for advice but I think the
hardest thing understandably has just
been like the hours is really really
tough and I think partly that's what led
to the burnout of mean leaving so you
need to be ready for that so how did how
did you stretch it then was it you know
I started at 8am finished at like 10 11
p.m at night every day really yeah but
again that wasn't enforced by anyone
else besides myself and you can
definitely do it a lot better I just had
this goal in mind and I would do any
thing to hit that goal
um so and like I was saying to you Alex
earlier us sorry Americans are crazy and
they're all up at like 3 A.M in the
morning ready to go so you might think
think that the time difference is a
negative yeah cold calling at 3M no I
my best client actually that I got from
a cold call came from a VP of Business
Development like a 800 person
biochemistry company in the USA and he
was on a StairMaster at 4am in the
morning
I don't think there's ever a good or bad
time to be honest
um but yeah I just love the US they're a
lot more honest and there's none like
none of this polite that us
Brits like to Endeavor on
um but yeah I've loved it and the
salaries are obviously a lot higher very
very difficult regarding different
legalities in different states and every
state has a different cultural aspect as
well like personally I don't love
working in the midwest but I like
Western East you've just got to find
your your Flair but yeah I've just kind
of winged it and it's worked okay Carl
now you're early on talked us about you
know what's worked what hasn't because
you're early on in the January aren't
you yeah we're very early on and to be
honest it is tough and it has been
really tough for us so very much in our
infancy and to be fair be Keen to speak
to anyone here that's been on that
Journey as well because we're still very
much in learning phase
um what's worked for us at the minute is
our prospecting method because the
people that we sell into they do the
same thing so although they may not be
recruiting we've been having a lot of
positive feedback on the Outreach which
has given us just some reassuring signs
for when the market becomes more buoyant
and comes back so that has been working
um I'll Prospect him and the candidate
attraction side from what we've
experienced in the last three months
actually been quite straightforward
again that's probably down to the market
but that's not been an issue the big
challenge for us though has been just
winning clients
um and the advice I would give for
anyone that's looking to do the US I
would make sure you've got your UK or
your core Market in order and kind of
nailed down first and just made sure you
do your due diligence
um first of all and we thought we had it
all planned out I mean we do we've got
the Market Marked we know what type of
businesses we want to sell to and then
we realize our domain is dot Co dot UK
and you're like oh wow
um all the little things that you're
just naive to that you don't realize
um so yeah just make sure you do your
due diligence uh first would be would be
have you approached the hours because I
know that's been a bit of a challenge
for you as well now how have you
structured the hours for the the yeah so
we structured the hours the legend that
is Sam he's in the audience some work on
some I think he's got a BD call shortly
so the hours that we do uh 10 a.m to 8pm
Monday to Thursday and we have a 3 P.M
finish on a Friday
um so some still benefits from the 3pm
Finish which we think is really
important because there's a lot of
sacrifice do in the US yeah and
particularly being the first person to
do it so we still want that element of
inclusion and being involved in the
bigger picture so that's how we're
structuring the I was at the moment it's
working okay for now we may tweet them
um but for you know the East Coast it's
not too bad
um and then I guess Alex anything's out
because you guys are a bit further along
right in the process of having people
move there setting up an office you know
so I'm assuming you know there's
obviously probably been mistakes and
challenges but you've built enough
traction to invest in you know feet on
the ground people there so talk to us a
bit about from your perspective a bit
further along principles to you know
making it a success in the US so far
that you guys have learned I think it
sounds really great what the two guys
have already said
um I think yeah you have to build a
business before you before you move
across I think that's really important
that there is a lot of sacrifice
involved in that and like even the guys
in the UK at the moment who were at the
US market you know I've got a huge
amount of respect for them because you
do have to sacrifice certain elements of
your your life basically to be able to
work the hours
um I think then it's about ensuring that
you've got the right team to go across
so I think it's all well and good you
know strategies I think the people come
first before the strategy sometimes
um especially in recruitment when it's
you know Professional Services etc etc
it's people-led so I just think you need
to make sure you've got a really crack
team to send across and you need to send
across enough people so that you're kind
of managing risk a little bit there
because there's the possibility
someone's going to move to a new new
country and say you know what actually
this isn't for me so you need a really
really good team you need to build
business before you go across you've got
an immediate base that you can work from
and expand out of and tap into New
Opportunities when you do do go across
there
um and as I say I think you need to
scale and you need the right people cool
one or two last questions for me then
and then we'll we'll I'll bring the
microphone in the audience so Carl let
me come tune uh This One 360 or 180
models what what do you prefer
for us I am 180 just suits our market so
much better I'm in the 360 model does
work can work even in one of the teams
in our business there's a case it will
work as well
um but I think for what we do there's
just so much work that goes in hence why
I said before we've started the SDR
model as well
um there's a reason that we place sdrs
into jobs that are very highly paid
because it is a full-time job
um but somehow as recruiters we expect
people to generate opportunities book
meetings managing accounts agree the
contracts then find the candidates it's
just too much so I think in some markets
it can work the way our business model
is set up it doesn't so we have it split
we've got a couple people that do 360
and it can work
um in certain markets but for me
and for a lot of businesses I'm not sure
it works personally Alex 360 180. they
both personally I think they both work
like I I'm a 180 guy so that's my
background and we've been playing around
with that a little bit of strive to make
sure it works for everyone I think
you've got to tailor it to the
individual first and foremost so there
are some people who are suitable to 360
and then there's other people who really
enjoy the hunting and there's other
people who enjoy the farming so I think
you can play to people's strengths I
think strength strength based management
is super important
um but but the truth is if you look at
some of the fastest growing recruitment
companies coming out of the UK at the
moment they do 360 models so although
that's not my my um my personal
preference I you know I think you've
just got to pick a model that works best
based upon your market and then and then
make sure that your systems and
structure are really sort of you know
slick and what's been your experience
despite being 360 myself I'm a 180
Advocate which again hypocritical
um but having said that I do think 360
suits a very very minute amount of
people like I just love 360 like that's
what I love being able to do tons of
different things and learn from
different aspects of the process but it
doesn't work
for everyone and also I think in
agencies if you do have like 50 360
recruiters they have no dependency on
you you kind of think okay what does an
agency or we actually providing and you
know that's why I might have moved on to
start my own agency I kind of feel like
I can do it all myself so you have no
dependency to the agency so sounds a bit
twisted but you do kind of need to think
about that as well so final one for me
um we've spoken a lot today around you
know winning new business new clients so
Carl let me come back to you what
obviously I speak to a lot of different
companies and when I find out you know
the most uh common way they either maybe
get candidates clients oftentimes it can
be referrals for a lot of companies it
isn't so you know I think sometimes like
like you said Amber when you achieved
those goals it was always a new logos
new clients right which is crazy like
imagine what you could do if these
people were giving you more than one
opportunity or whatever so let's just
end with it and I'll go into the
audience Carl what's like you know your
principles of actually building a
successful referral program even for you
know the client side of the candidate
side because I think that's also a
missed opportunity for people to think
about what more could they get out of
their existing relationships
yeah I think client referables for us
have been key and we've we've had a few
new client wins that have come from
referrals
um do you need a program as such or an
incentive for referrals on the client
side I don't think you do then the
biggest Advocate and Ambassador for
generating referrals is just how good
your level of services I think if you
deliver exceptionally wealthier clients
which you should be doing now and then
just asking them for referrals you know
reason that we've asked our existing
accounts for referrals within five
minutes we've had an email intro into a
new business as hiring
um but I think a lot of people probably
don't ask
um so for me I don't think you need a
program or maybe for candidate side yeah
I think that would incentivize people to
refer on the client side I think the
best thing you can do is deliver
exceptional service and just ask
tell me what was Alex from your journey
yeah I think that's really good advice
um one of the things we did at liquid
which massively increased our referrals
we we implemented MPS so I'm assuming
most people know what MPS is but it was
a brilliant way to change the culture of
our business a little bit because we
were really like
um sales focused organizations not
organization I think sometimes that had
a little bit of an impact upon our our
culture with regards to having a
customer first sort of mindset and a
candidate first mindset so we
implemented MPS which gave us the
ability to be able to really effectively
measure our customer satisfaction levels
which first and foremost changed the
mindset of the people in the business
because they knew that that all of a
sudden was something that was massively
important to us and I think also it
gives you a brilliant way to be able to
identify Learning and Development
opportunities but also there's a sales
trigger there so when you have someone
come back and say exceptional service
levels all of a sudden that's the
perfect time to be speaking to that
individual to maximize their verbal
opportunities so I think as a way of
like object object focusing on customer
service levels and object objectively
being able to measure them and drive
improvements throughout your business
including in Canada and client
generation I think it's um it's it's a
good tip for anyone out there thinking
about how they can focus in on that
stuff
I don't Amber should I ask you because
I don't know how many referrals you got
me
[Music]
um I don't you think like as recruiters
we we get how like easy it is to just
ask for referrals like how many of us
are actually asking probably not that
many and obviously this has been
something that's top of my mind starting
a new business and how easy is it to
have a lovely call with one of your
existing clients be like Jane I've loved
working I love that you're diverse we've
had an amazing honest like open
communication is there anyone else in
your network that shares our same values
that you could introduce me to like that
is so much easier than doing 262 dolls
or whatever I did and being told
off once and it yeah and then it will
equate to clients that do replicate the
traits of the clients that you already
work with that you do like and that do
work with the way that that you work so
I think just don't us don't get and get
good at upfront contracts just to throw
in there like that was the thing I
always used to do so if
um this is our relationship what do you
want from me you know what do you think
I expect from you get a really clear
understanding from a client and from a
candidate what they want from the
relationship and then I think you can
close them on the fact if I do those
things for you how would you feel about
X how would you feel about recommending
me or introducing me into maybe three of
three colleagues that you know and
respect who are really strong within
your industry it doesn't matter whether
they're actively looking at that time or
not all I'm really asking for is the
opportunity to be introduced to maybe
three of your colleagues who I could you
know talk to about our services and see
whether I could help them further down
the line then focus in on those customer
service levels make sure that person's
really really happy if you can do it
objectively amazing that's even better
and then I think it's a case of
reminding them throughout the process
are you happy how are you finding the
service levels are we living up to the
expectations that we set ourselves at
the beginning and then at the end of
that process is the case of saying right
now give me the three names so I think
you can lock someone in early on in the
process live up to expectation and then
you know I I was quite good at referrals
and that was the typical sort of process
I used
cool right
thanks for listening let's look let's
get you involved I know sometimes we
need the first person to have the
courage and be brave to ask a question
all right let's let's kick this off then
right
I'm coming back
long time listen a first time caller
thank you I appreciate that
um look I'm a business owner and I see
the struggles that you guys go through
trying to motivate staff and everything
like that and I think it's false economy
for everyone to believe right now that
it is the good old days of recruitment
it definitely is not I'm sure you'll all
agree uh it's harder than it ever has
been for you to attract for you to
actually demonstrate your Worth to
clients yeah what I want to know is when
we talk about what separates somebody
from a good Builder to a great Builder
what separates that two percent five
percent that are actually you know
flying and still flying through these
economic uncertain times what are the
consistent traits that these people show
and the delivering day in day out that
can hopefully influence everyone else
that maybe take that little bit away
from to actually apply to their daily
routine to make them that little bit
better
[Applause]
go for it
uh I think consistency is important so
again I think it's about having high
standards it's about knowing what works
from a process perspective it's about
understanding best practice within each
of those aspects of process it's about
maintaining those standards and having a
continual focus on continuous
Improvement so what one thing that
worked really well for me was I just
gamified everything so literally every
single day I kind of played a game where
I'd say if I do X and Y I wonder if I
can get better at this so this is where
I'm at currently this is what I'm
looking to achieve moving forward can I
move the needle on this particular
aspect so
um that that for me I I had that like
consistent approach to that and I think
that then feeds through to the rest of
the team because you know especially in
downturn markets recruitment is a pretty
brutally horrible job at times so I
think you've got to find wins in what
you do on a day-to-day basis outside of
just the success that comes from making
a placement an earning commission so if
you can make those wins kind of gamified
with regards to getting better at what
you do and again I'm like a broken
record if you can attach like metrics
and numbers to that so you can actually
see quantifiable improvements that for
me like really I always really bought
into that because it meant that I could
actually see I was getting better so it
always felt like I was improving can I
just go a little step deeper so we talk
you talk about how I could do it how you
could do it how can everyone else do it
what would you expect in your team for
them to progress themselves how would
you encourage them to go that little
step further because it's all I'm good
saying well this is what I would do but
how would you encourage everyone else to
do that I think you've got to lead by
example and then you you can't over
communicate the important stuff so but
be the change you want to see in the
world and so someone quoted that
somewhere I don't know I'm a bit worried
who I've just quoted there because I
don't know if it's a really bad human
being I apologize
um
but I think yeah that you you've got a
lead by example and you've got to be
what you want to see on your sales floor
and then you've just got to communicate
that like relentlessly when you get to
the point where people roll their eyes
because you're saying the same thing
over and over again and they know what
you're going to say you're kind of at
the point where actually that stuff's
starting to sink in so I think it's
about really effective communication and
leading by example because if you talk
about marginal gains and continuous
Improvement all the time and show them
how that can benefit them people buy
into that stuff
um so I don't know if that answers the
question anymore nice
who else we got who else has a question
for them who has the the courage there's
definitely a couple more for sure
yeah
have you not sure anyone else
yeah the front
there you go
um so
I'm actually interested to hear the
answer to this from a personal
perspective so I joined the recruitment
industry in 2021 where it was so buoyant
like right at the beginning it was a
brilliant brilliant year and obviously
we're in a downturn market now but quite
a few different occasions I've heard
people saying that the market conditions
are actually very similar to pre-covered
times and it's now a really saturated
Market where it's really difficult to BD
but you guys have been here pre-covered
is it similar or are we going to see a
market turn and the Market's going to
become less less saturated with
recruiters so we'll see an upturn or is
it very similar to pre-covered
I'll chip in on that first so I'd say
for us we are at pre-covered levels uh
however I think everything is magnified
as 10 times worse because of how good
2021 and the beginning of 2022 was so
yeah I think to give some reassurance to
everyone it's not massively dissimilar
to probably what it was three years ago
just feels a lot worse
um and I think a lot of the people in
the industry now probably didn't know
what it used to be like so their
comparison is amazing absolutely
terrible
um so yeah hopefully that answers the
question I think it is pretty similar
from what we've noticed in terms of job
flow revenue and everything else
I think this is personally as well for
me why I find this question so hard to
answer because I've been tracking for
example in my own Market in biotech how
many vacancies every day are uploaded
and there's actually way more for me
right now than there were in that boom
time so I'm kind of like playing Devil's
Advocate with myself but one thing
that's completely made recruitment for
me personally more difficult is AI in
our market for example there are lots of
academic institutions that have ai
platforms that basically do the whole
recruitment process for them so think
about how AI is also affecting your
market and how that might be playing a
part in the inability to get as many
vacancies like I think we're really not
focusing on how much this is going to
affect our lives as recruiters and if
you're not learning at least how to use
AI you're gonna be behind
definitely got time for one more if
anyone wants to ask one more question
you go on
huh
join the microphone or are you good
I can't let me I'll give you
no no come on we yeah but we're
recording it
hang with some recruitment for a very
very long time I don't know
daring to have a uterus and a womb and
using it twice
um it can be
yeah to the wound no it can be it can be
quite a tricky industry for females to
be in and I felt like quite a lot of my
career has been a bit of a fight and so
I'm quite interested to ask the panel
um
what are you doing to support women in
your business and not just women like
diversity because there's so many people
that say it's a tick box exercise and
nominate themselves for rewards and all
that bollocks and on LinkedIn but what
are you actually doing like day to day
to genuinely support women
I don't think
love that question by the way that's
right
the problem is companies aren't doing
anything right that's why I want to
start my own bloody female empowered
recruitment business because
I want to implement all those things I
want to have flexible working so women
can still be successful Builders and
have a family and not feel like
they're a burden I want women to be able
to have firm maternity leave I want
women to be able to have role models
that they can aspire to be because it's
so difficult to envisage yourself in a
position where it's just a room of white
men whereby you can't even like get your
point across in meetings because your
voice is biologically so much quieter
than theirs like it's draining
and unfortunately I don't think right
now there's an answer to that question
but all we can do as women who care
about making these changes is keep
advocating and keep telling our stories
and keep being open about these shitty
experiences that we've had because I
think often people think that these
things aren't happening but it's a daily
struggle sometimes just trying
to get your opinion heard
um so I'm right there with you
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't follow I can't follow that
yikes sorry I thought it really scary
then didn't I oh you nailed it
yeah cool
um that is all yeah Fair well we're
gonna end on that note I think just just
a quick bit of housekeeping before we
finish bars open here for another 20
minutes uh so definitely grab a drink
and then we can all go back upstairs the
networking area
um but look Carl Alex Amber thank you
let's put our hands together for these
guys thank you so much everyone
thank you